[Musique]
et une nouvelle arrestation dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur les violences
des zoulous les zoulous ce sont ces
bandes qui s'était tristement rendu
célèbre au mois de juillet dernier par
un meurtre à la défense et aussi par
l'assassinât d'un épicier ce phénomène
des bandes
on en parle beaucoup depuis en fait elle
existe depuis plusieurs années mais
toutes heureusement non pas pour credo
la violence est d'ailleurs ce meurtre a
été un véritable choc pour tous ces
gamins qui appartiennent plus ou moins
aux bandes les halls ou donc comme on
les appelle sur fond de musique rap et
de banlieue en quête d' anne consigny
banlieue ils sont copains mais ne leur
dites surtout pas qu'ils forment une
bande de zulu même s'ils en ont la lure
il aurait trop peur que ça les classe
parmi les voyous sa dégaine de chapeau
l'angleterre aussi l'amérique acheté en
amérique chez sur eux
est ce que vous vous diriez vous êtes
des sunu ça ne peut rien dire maintenant
parce que normalement un zoulou c'est un
mec qui retranscrit sur l'énergie
négative en énergie positive
à la base ce afrika bambaataa kaka mais
ce moment aux états unis tout ça parce
que ça ne les retrouve dans le bronx et
doit faire un mouvement nation puisque
la vanne unity est bon ben on a sous
loué les médias il appelle à zulu un mec
qui dépouillent et où la soul ou c'est
un mec positif qui qui théoriquement
boit pas elle fume pas tout ça enfin
maintenant quoi quand on entend parler
que des bagarres il ya même des mets des
meurtres carrément bas on se sent mal à
l'aise qua na qui veulent faire ce super
connaître et ben voilà ils y vont ils
tapent quelqu'un comme ça ouais j'ai
tapé lui je suis dangereux je fais gaffe
à moi quand tu me vois tu le respectes
c'est mal ça très sympa pour eux fini
donc le terme soul ou jean françois et
karim vous diront qu'ils font partie
d'une louve du mouvement à la fois un
style musical
une philosophie de la vie est un art
vestimentaire importé de préférence des
états unis le berceau du mouvement
là bas ils sont vraiment à la mode se
cache pas ses plus jeunes quoi si tu
veux dans le langage dans le langage
français c'est plus fun quoi est bon
pour eux aussi sont publicité quoi c'est
dire si c'est qu'on côtoie éclate onemi
carson 15 ans lui aussi fait partie du
move
tous les mercredis il anime une émission
sur radio beur les invités ils parlent
de leur musique le rap de graffitis et
même des aspects les plus négatifs du
mouvement la bagarre ni carson lui aussi
passé par là même si aujourd'hui sur les
ondes
il fustige la violence je m'occuperai
lors d'affaires je crois très bien mon
ami trop sexy afin que moi je touche
beaucoup en hiver et dans le journal
vous et galfond ce top 20 de dans le
plus souvent pour rentrer dans le groupe
qui tu veux fallait pas faire un test
l'été il fallait pas abattre l espace
contre le chef le chef de la bande ou
contre le shekel trouve comme ça et puis
si tu perdais tout de suite tu devais
qu'a fait la gueule tout de suite bon
c'était pas la peine tu étais pas pris
merci où tu joues tu gagnes ou tu
résistes est un bon bout de temps
voilà tu étais pris quoi voilà je
pouvais être ensemble pour beaucoup le
passage par les bandes et la bagarre
c'est une étape obligée pour apprendre
la vie aujourd'hui karim et johnny
racontent leur histoire de dépouilles au
passé moi je marchais dans la rue y
avait un mec qui marche et qui rentre
dz il fallait qu'ils me donnent cette
rencontre montre la grâce est ce
patron était tous
je les fais tout ça les jeux les faux
bond
on peu dépouillé quelqu'un sans qu'il le
sache donc on peut le dépouiller avec
violence il peut le dépouiller callao
coup de pression quoi la tchatche quoi
avoir la tâche le met sur la flip un cas
la parole du bon si ça marche pas la
parole
l'étape numéro de quoi on la plupart ils
finissent un jour par se remettre dans
la bonne voie pour un boulot ou une
femme
le risque vient des très jeunes qui sont
déjà allés loin dans la violence ou des
plus vieux qui n'arrivent pas à s'en
sortir après 25 ans
[Musique]